[Musique]
mais c'est la vie si tout concorde est
astucieux mais
la furie cette issue le plus sérieux à
jouer et le dit vouloir devenir amis
bonjour tout cas encore aujourd'hui on
jouera tous bonjour à tous
ah non c'est pas une réception à non non
je n'étais pas invitée pour voir ces
deux vers l'expérience c'est une
expérience
oui oui c'est je voudrais que le petit
s'en aille
pourquoi parce que ça peut sauter ah bon
tu dois oui ça fait même dangereux alors
si tout va du temps que vous profitiez
20 20 d'entre nous bon alors il faut
manger à fabrice wii fait rentrer ce ver
dans l'autre attends je comprends pas
bien là tu veux dire le simple le verre
de vin qui se trouvent ici sparadrap
s'est pas passé dans le diamant qui se
trouve là voilà oui mais comment abbas
et voilà tout le problème est là
oui bah je sais pas moi alors c'est pas
facile hein bon tu veux que je t'aide à
lait de noix un petit coup de main tu as
tu un petit carton là oui bon tu poses
le carton sur le verre d'eau as tu veux
que je le pose de façon à le boucher
hermétiquement battant savez j'avais
déjà fait ça une fois oui bon temps tu
renverses où il renverse le tout oui
alors je renverse le tout tu m'avais
sever sur l'autre bien bien beau à bord
oui tu parles comme c'est facile ça bien
bord à bord tu dis oui oui prend 10 dont
j'ai pris ça devrait ça devrait à peu
près à peu près marché alors maintenant
oui tu n'en laissait tu n'enlève pas le
socle assure le non non non je descends
qui touche pourtant juste oui qu'est ce
que je fais et tu enlèves le papier
peint tout doucement alors tout
doucement
oui pour laisser une ouverture oui pas
être facile ça ça je sens que ça après
si je sens que ça va pulser serait
facile mon pauvre fabrino je n'y arrive
pas à je regrette de ne pas avoir demain
tu t'y attends je suis très inquiet là
tu tires ça vient je sois là c'est très
bien fabrice comme ça là voilà tu crois
le chant petit passage et qu'est-ce qui
va se faire
et voilà un nom tout deal et le vin
vente où ça va pas monter
je la dis tu deviens monte à la tête là
ils m'ont mis là il monte dans le fond
de votre verre
j'en ai un petit peu plus pour ça il
plus vite oui il voir car il veut que je
te fasse le bruit blues ont marqué blues
c'est formidable on voit le levain
monter dans l'eau regarder ça se colore
déjà nettement et vous voyez très bien
au dessus du verre le levain qui
s'agglutinent ici là c'était cet
étonnant ce truc là mais ça c'est faire
du regard attend on le regarde encore un
tout petit peu c'est tellement joli et
après ça va remplacer complètement ali
j'aurais bien aimé le faire avec deux
verres d'eau mais alors on ne va rien le
problème c'est qu'on voit on ne voit
rien du pays ben je vous propose une
chose mon cher tout blanco c'est que
nous laissions cette expérience
continuer sans nous et peut-être si nous
avons le temps nous y reviendrons plus
tard pour voir où ça en est puis-je être
félicités à là je dois dire que tu m'a
étonné tu sais ce tour là il est
formidable oh il y bien et bien dès
maintenant on en rit maintenant ça se
voit très nettement
maintenant elle va très bien le mot à
mot givet ok c'est le mot à mot et oui
au rouge leur épargne et or ça c'était
vraiment formidable ce système la fac je
leur fasse ça m'a plu c'est le mot
tamment avec bien entendu des cartons
sur lesquels sont dessinés des objets
des choses des animaux représentant une
syllabe et après avec cécile à bhl nous
formons d'autres mots c'est un jeu qui
demande beaucoup d'attention car ce
n'est pas facile
et jusqu'ici je crois que vous avez
gagné les uns les autres successivement
usa vont pratiquement tous go et marché
très bien alors c'est un très bon show
est-ce que je
attendez carte tous leurs cinq cartes je
prends 5
oui alors attendu 5
voilà voilà
la première c'est la terre n'est ce pas
la deuxième qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est pierre 2 ou wii direz vous ça
c'est un vrai à ça c'est un garçon qui
s'occupe des chevaux qui les panses
terra chevalier c'est un an
c'est un lad la lad rad un lad ladd et
puis ça c'est un pan j'ai alors voilà
chacun se concentre et chacun essaie
avec ce syllabe de former un mort et
j'ai une idée servoz oui j'ai une idée
oui tu as une idée tout encore c'est
quoi
rond attend à et en a tant donné ce
christ et ridha ben tu aimes la panthère
votre temps ban attend bon terme portée
voilà voilà
bon à la panthère panthères panthères
voilà tu veux pouces moussu tête pour
écrire panthères oui parce que
brusquement je vous pose une question
c'est bien comme ça non vaut mieux pas
voilà voilà
erreur voilà une panthère avec des loups
restent à je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
faire grand chose nous attend qu'est ce
que tu en penses à brice vos révolat
delà drainons lalala leur tire encore un
carton
oui encore un carton france attendait ça
c'était des temps ddd là je peux me
permettre à windows a coupé quelques
coups là que j'ai une bonne idée
et à ben oui à vas-y on peut faire des
si tu sors le dérider le veau des vos
sorts leveaux oui et leur est ainsi du
buzz l'omi bien joué ça rapido dès lors
et dévoré vauré dévorer des mourides est
passé bien alors voilà le des d'abord
des veaux mais bien joué bien joué il
n'y pensez pas bravo rapide aux nazis
joly viendra alors que nous avons des
baux ruraux une ré dévorer de bien jouer
panthère et dévoré bravo bravo rapidos
quel meilleur aujourd'hui je te félicite
à à oui c'est très très bien veux-tu me
montrer une lettre cl d'eau sel là j'ose
non mais si c'est là bas c'est fait
c'est fait je voudrais que ce soit une
petite fille attends je vais te dire ça
tout de suite
c'est une lettre qui vient c'est un
petit garçon dont rabat c'est un garçon
vous atterri dans une autre lettre
frédéric gaillard qui habite champigny
bonsoir frédéric et frédéric nous
raconte des tas de petites histoires
très sympathique il vous aime bien mais
vous dit bonjour à tous quand rapido ça
pousse pousse suis à bell bell est
stoppée et il est très fidèle à cette
émission il la regarde régulièrement etc
etc
nous en sommes absolument ravis fédéric
si tu le veux bien je crois que tout
cancan oui j gâteau j'ai quelque chose à
dire oui il ya kg je voudrais qu'on
regarde le vert maintenant de mon
expérience enfin jeter un coup d'oeil
est extraordinaire regardes tu vois où
ça en est c'est fou le vin est passée
complètement au dessus éleveurs du
dessous c'est maintenant presque
complètement de l'eau en cette étonnante
elle est formidable et comme ça sinon
bon le petit frédéric reçoit un disque
avec la chanson des quatre amis oui je
crois qu'il faudra il pourra la prendre
lui aussi comment j'ai des jeunes
et une bonne équipe c'est ça ta ta ta ta
ta ta bouche reçu ça va et anonymat ça
va être à nous alors tu vas au tableau
tu m'entends petit marqueurs comme
études
bon alors un mot en huile être à qui
commence par un f f comme fernand alors
1 2 3 4 5 6 ce sont des traits pour les
lettres qui monte oui et la dernière un
t1 t1 tt voilà transport toujours
toujours à transpole moyen de transport
moyen dans les airs très spécial a non
pas dans les airs sur route
un patio route sur la mer assure la mer
jaune là mais principalement oui oui oui
abbas est une sorte de bateau je suis
une sorte de bathory une sorte de button
s'en tenait un bar de bateaux de guerre
non c'est pas un bateau de guerre dont
un bateau de transport civil un
transport civilistes rend ce portrait
délits qu l'oci ah ah et si je te
donnais une lettre vas-y 1 la troisième
oui la troisième médecin r allez là tu
dois trouver facilement et tu me dis
qu'ils transportent des à une petite
seconde prochaine au début qu'une mais
tu as des gâteaux combien m mais tu dis
qu'il y avait deux lettres en huile être
assez pas possible ça peut commencer par
annonce et papa s'il a déjà trouvé à moi
je suis sûr qu'il s'agit d'un ferry boat
la série hbo et ben oui ben ferry boat
ça ne s'écrit pas avec une aide commenté
chris allan ça s'écrit bien fe2 air y
plus loin bo t ferry moment c'est pas
ben est haute et ça c'est complètement
fou pour push moussu un ferry boat ça
vient de l'anglais et ça s'écrit comme
cela f2r y là nous sommes d'accord prêt
d'union mais là ça change tout ces boat
bateau en anglais b o a été voilà
comment il faut écrire ferry boat pouces
ou si on écoutait pas
vraiment s'il faut connaître l'anglais
rembotte même ses pompes à faire des
fautes d'orthographe déjà ici l'enfance
entre copains le mieux c'est d'aller
retrouver belle belle parce que ça
glisse bien jouer avec moi là c'est pas
si la musique tibétains partie musicale
un peu
tiens compris musée le jouer oui bon
alors tu complète les mots que je ne
dirais pas en entier à l'aide d'une note
de musique et oui à la fin ces notes te
donneront le début de la chanson dont
voici l'histoire parfait cette histoire
c'est un problème
et comme tous les problèmes il a une
mission et une solution seuls 6 mai oui
et pour trouver cette solution il ne
faut pas être marque droit et mama la
droite la droite et l'athénée n'est pas
mieux mais au bas merci à le bon dieu
merci
donc mon histoire c'est celle d'une
chèvre ballet qui n'est pas
particulièrement s'ils dos il est patent
voilà une chaîne qui ne veut pas bouger
de l'endroit où elle est on a vous
l'appelez elles ne pipent ont pas elles
ne répondent pas elle ne les abris font
pas et tu sais cette chèvre
elle est pourtant à sable d'eau râble
adorable voilà les tissus et très
indisciplinée sublime est parfait tout
le monde s'y met pour essayer de la
faire sortir de son coin mais personne
n'y avait eu aussi les rues us patent et
maintenant on regarde des notes ça fait
la chanson là ici dorais dos ici et bien
c'est parfait
oui j'suis pas celui qui t'habille qui
suit pas sûr de moi la poésie comme un
petit peu je sais pas qu'est ce que tu
vas faire sourire parfait à thé sahraoui
latapie voilà ça la cédraie dodo c'est
la seule façon
oui oui mais si je ne l'avais pas si sûr
y est tu ne l'aurais pas chanter c'est
vrai je me sens comme un petit tout
petit don est bien de voltige et pour
l'autre mais c'était pas évident via
voir fabrice il lui a posé une plume
depuis hier soir j'arrive il est mignon
comment va ton papa leurs clips dont les
dates samedi son départ n'a pas d'amis
les tags sa fille vous diront petits
secrets que la vie majeur et désiste et
rzeszow fait des choses mais comme je
n'ai pas de minois les gros rabais
attention les quatre amis sont traqués
sans répit et qu'axa me sens heureux car
il aime la vie
[Musique]
les gars
ni aujourd'hui les
ses amis de vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]
g
oui
[Musique]